[Musique]
retour à bien saint-jean-de-luz au pays
basque avec dominique langard dominique
lang art qui nous attendent devant le
cinéma magique à saint-jean-de-luz en
compagnie de quelqu'un que vous
connaissez bien eddy mitchell tout à
l'heure à 12h30 à saint-jean-de-luz on
va commencer voir commencer les prises
de vues pour la dernière séance eddy
mitchell vous enregistre à une série de
quatre émissions à saint-jean-de-luz
pour cette dernière séance pourquoi vous
avez choisi saint jean de luz avalanche
je ne crois pas et surtout en fonction
jeudi
vieille salle de ces humains donc vrai
que aussi bien jullianges dans les
grandes villes
ce qui ne s'est pas à marseille bordeaux
paris et chez perrin on a beaucoup de
mal je lirai à trouver à trouver des
salles correspondante à l'époque
et quand on en trouve on peut vous ne
pouvez pas je veux dire forcément en
bonne condition pour tourner pour des
raisons je dire de circulation
agréable en maintenant une liste assez
impressionnante de vieilles salles de
cinéma en france
oui mais enfin ça c'est vrai c'est comme
les anciens combattants ça tourne
toujours par monts jura jour ou l'autre
c'est donc dans les vieilles salles
deviennent des nouvelles en vie tant
comme en trois salles papier du verre ce
qu'on appelle dans les sondages des
coûte votre émission la dernière séance
répartis des meilleures émissions de ce
qu'on appelle la nouvelle télévision
pourquoi à votre avis la parole devant
des gens qui la regarde parce que moi je
suis pas un homme de télévision j'ai
fait une émission vraiment en balisant
c'est vrai c'était d'abord s'aider
suprêmement qui me font remarquer qu'ils
m'ont amusé donc ils font partie qui
font partie je veux dire de ma vie donc
je sais pas moi je le jure que ça marche
ou pas je leur ai fait de cette façon là
donc peux pas l'expliquer vélo vraiment
de celle acheteurs pendant les français
que les films que vous proposez son et
films dont le public a besoin que le
public peut réclamer théâtre n'ont de
toute façon ceux des films même si on
les connaît pas on en prend quand même
plein la figure puisque c'est un cinéma
vont qui ne qu'il ne peut plus n'a plus
de raison d'être pour les raisons
financières parce qu'on ne peut plus
alors par exemple pour le changer
n'importe pas le signe de zorro c'est
complètement
ça peut paraître bélisle pour certains
ça peut paraître absolument
délicieusement est trop pour d'autres si
on veut prendre un accent ce 9 et de
toute façon c'est les films qu'on coûter
très très cher
alors maintenant comme on travaille un
peu à l'économie c'est impossible de
refaire eau et en faisant un très bon
moyen donc c'est pour eux c'est le pire
la télévision c'est le seul moyen de de
pouvoir voir ses films puisque de toute
façon qu'on ne peut pas également
ressortir ses films en circuits normaux
puisque ça demanderait un investissement
énorme pour peut-être un gain ridicule
et dans le cinéma actuel ou très proches
de nous associer à des films qui vous
intéresseraient ah ben non il ya
beaucoup de films qui m'intéressent mais
bien entendu correspondre à l'esprit de
votre émission
oui bon
on tombe on tombe dans des choses qui
n'ont pas besoin de la télévision de la
guerre des étoiles à la télévision sur
youtube puisque c'est un truc comme ça
tu veux ça besoin d'un écran 60 mm ça a
besoin de d'un son stéréo et c'est pas
avec les appareils du temps pour ça la
première des émissions de vous
enregistrer à saint-jean-de-luz passera
quand elle passera fin